Dragon Ball Z Dragon Ball super one of
these shows has more detractors than the
other and I wanted to iron out why
specifically to communicate my feelings
of how one might feel much less
emotionally rich visually diverse and
structurally sound than the other and to
do this I wanted to look through the
prism of the Saiyan Prince Vegeta I want
to look through how these two shows
structured their stories around him to
deliver his highs his lows and how they
attempted to deliver the most memorable
moments for the character from when he
was first introduced during the Saiyan
arc in the 1980s to modern-day tellings
of the story within Dragon Ball super
manga during the more arc I will be
following Vegeta's journey dragon ball
super sequel series has been labeled
everything under the Sun from
disappointing to tragic with plenty
loving the show from start to finish so
let's see where the differences lie and
if they can be justified
this is Vegeta supers boring see
to borrow a quote from Robert McKee the
function of structure is to provide
progressively building pressures that
force characters into more and more
difficult dilemmas where they must make
more and more risk-taking choices and
actions gradually revealing their true
natures
even down to the unconscious self this
is an important and somewhat
illuminating quote to me because when I
use it in conjunction with someone like
Vegeta it can be incredibly accurate in
describing his journey through Dragon
Ball Z as it can most characters but
what's interesting specifically about
Vegeta is that he began not as one with
the pressure being put on him but the
wound applying pressure to Goku and the
others in the sand saga which means that
despite someone being utilized as a
down-and-out two-dimensional
bad-to-the-bone character as long as
it's carried out with consideration as
well as the correct amount of time and
effort any character can go from being
the one applying the pressure to being
the one changed by it you just need to
have the right sort of pressure with the
correct motivations
[Music]
the Nemec arced directly after the fight
with Goku on earth can be seen as the
first time Vegeta really started to
garner some emotional depth and range as
a character typically speaking before
you introduce a character into a story
whether it be a villain hero mentor etc
most writers will tell you it's
important to fully understand the
background of and know the personality
of the character first and in the case
of Vegeta it was important to fully
understand what he wants what he needs
and what he was capable of as a
character these are specific topics I've
covered in other videos like my one on
trunks so if you haven't seen that
already check it out the thing your
character wants will almost always be
something external something physical
he's trying to solve his inner emptiness
with external solutions he thinks that
if he could just get this one thing
everything will be perfect that he'll be
powerful respected and most importantly
fulfilled because at the moment
he most definitely is not happy now
oftentimes with characters like this the
things that they want could be perfectly
respectable goals now in the case of
Vegeta universe white domination isn't
exactly reasonable but nevertheless
issues arise when these characters are
pursuing goals that are furthering their
enslavement to the lies they hold to be
true which leads me to what Vegeta's
character actually needs now this is the
part a lot of novice writers forget
about and it's the part that gives the
most emotional depth to a character so
at this point the story Vegeta has been
living by this toxic misconception and
misconception over what was truly
important something that holds him back
and something that prevents him from
growing emotionally now the antidote to
this in a word simply is the truth that
it doesn't make you weak to care about
someone or show affection for them in a
more general sense the thing your
character will need oftentimes won't be
physical it won't be material usually
hinging on so emotional characteristic
being denied or pushed to the wayside in
Vegeta's case it was empathy and love I
mean it wouldn't be much of a story of
all Vegeta's misconception was was
physical with it being an emotional
abstract concept it lends credence to
the likelihood of him not noticing it
and having to be taught to embrace it
later however because emotional growth
isn't exactly a tangible thing and
really can't be seen as a writer you
need a physical embodiment or
manifestation of the mo
Grosse Vegeta in this case undergoes
this is why we have scenes like his
death anomic where go coup arrives
demonstrating to him all of his mistakes
and trunks been shot by cells showing
him that he really does care about his
son it's nothing more than a
split-second realization in a number of
cases all delivered by consistent
pressure being applied to this specific
area of his psyche however the most
interesting part of this characters
growth has to be how it's all tied
together in Dragon Ball Z near the end
of his story in the final saga of the
show Vegeta is asked as a character to
choose between what he really wants and
what he actually needs in his specific
case he's asked to choose between the
ultimate power he wants to destroy Goku
and the family and loved ones he
actually needs this is the reason why
for many Vegeta's returned to the
dioxide in the Buu saga was so powerful
and compelling through years of great
terrific character building we fully
understood what Vegeta wanted and we
knew he was making a massive mistake in
taking this course of action however we
could all understand his thought process
in doing so this is tremendously
compelling character running and it's
largely why Vegeta was the best
character by far in my estimation during
the boos
for those that are interested in a more
complex nuance of character writing
Vegeta underwent during this section of
the story
a miniature negative change arc
something that's specifically called a
full arc in this arc the character
starts out just as he would in a
positive change arc already entrenched
in the line but unlike the positive
change arc in which he would eventually
overcome the light and embrace the truth
the protagonist in the fall arc will
reject every chance for embracing the
truth and will fall more and more deeply
into the madness of his own sins usually
dragging others along with them his
story will end in insanity obsessive
immorality or death and this was what
made Dragon Ball Z's Vegeta so
captivating because death doesn't carry
as much weight as it would in other
shows which normally is a bad thing
because of its perceived shortcomings
and stakes the upside that we get to see
in this instance is that we get to mix
and meld varying character archetypes
together resulting in Vegeta redeeming
himself in the afterlife resulting in a
completely fulfilled positive change
character arc by the end having admitted
to be lesser than Goku as a fighter but
realizing that he is just as rich as he
in the areas that actually matter and
that was the power of Dragon Balls
writing back in the day I believe
through and through Vegeta was the most
consistently compelling and well-written
character the entire series ever put to
paper now let's see how Dragon Ball
super handled it one of the major things
people enjoyed about Vegeta in the
original Dragon Ball story was that you
never really knew what would happen with
him he had this impulsive mentality that
promoted moments of great tension in
short he was an active car to that while
he was on the screen or had something to
say or do he would be moving the story
Ford to the benefit or to the detriment
of the main cast depending on how he was
feeling
however in Dragon Ball super he is very
much different very different and
strangely enough he's different because
he doesn't change he doesn't grow much
at all oddly enough he's different
because he relentlessly persists in
staying the exact same way he has been
since the beginning and this is in
essence because the structure of Dragon
Ball super was exceptionally unambitious
flat and at times somewhat vapid now
don't get me wrong Dragon Ball super has
delivered some extraordinary
strong episodes like episode 47 which
deliver tons of character rich dialogue
setups and debuts however the very
person who wrote that episode a to hero
Tomioka also wrote episode 67 which was
widely considered one of the most
uninspired confused rushed and poorly
executed endings the entire series has
seen while doing research for this video
I found a terrific quote what the novice
writer mistakes for craft is simply his
unconscious absorption of story elements
from every novel film or play he's ever
encountered as they write they match
their work by trial and error against a
model built up from accumulated reading
and watching the unschooled writer calls
this instant but it's merely habit and
it's rigidly limiting leading to them
either imitating their mental prototype
or imagines themselves in the oven guard
and repels against it what this means is
when someone new to the series watches
Dragonball Z they leave believing it's
successful because of climaxes like
Gohan vs. L or sacrifices like pickle
and Vegeta have made but in reality it's
the structure that laid the groundwork
for those instances to matter as much as
they did and what happens when you
remove all of the emotional meaning and
weight behind an action hoping that it
on its own is enough to make the scene
amazing you get scenes like this or if
you want another example you get this
moreover the very presence and failure
of these scenes ability to stand on
their own or to live up to the standard
of the originals that they're based on
only serve to highlight Dragon Ball
super shortcomings more the interest and
all that came from the original scenes
these were based on did not come from
the simple spectacle it provided so
readily but from the emotional meaning
and change of heart it represented in
the characters acting these scenes out
to expand on this point further I'd like
to take a look at this quote from Hayao
Miyazaki the major source for Japanese
animation is manga whose greatest
characteristic is its method of
expression centred on emotions in order
to express emotions space and time are
freely distorted this was a quote taken
from a larger interview Miyazaki
conducted as he lamented and explained
his thoughts on the popularity anime has
garnered in the West and across the
globe I'm a huge admirer of Miyazaki's
work and animation philosophy my
interpretation of this quote is that
animes X
pression of emotion is so potent because
of its grand sensational sense of scope
afforded to it by its stories due to the
nature of its medium in other words when
someone is sad angry or happy in anime
it's accentuated to deliver the
strongest impact it can and that's the
difference between Dragon Ball super and
Dragon Ball Z's Vegeta Hayao Miyazaki
much like myself and many others don't
care much for spectacle unless there's
an emotional weight behind it and it's
for that reason I care much more for
Vegeta's character during the Buu saga
that I did during his time in the
tournament of power it is for that very
reason I am interested keenly in this
moment from Vegeta's story and I'm not
interested at all in this one from
Dragon Ball super to further bolster
this line of criticism for those that
might disagree with it I ask you what
has changed about Vegeta or his current
situation since the end of battle of
gods the answer is very very little and
the troubles with that can be seen very
easily all of the Gena's monumental
moments in this series are rooted in
this archetype of change often times
positive change and sometimes a negative
one but a change nonetheless he isn't
forced to change in any meaningful
emotional way in Dragon Ball super
but the Reuters place him in
circumstances that are reminiscent of
his highlights in Dragon Ball Z in the
hopes that they will achieve what they
did for him in the past but they won't
they can't structurally speaking
narrative Lee speaking and logically
speaking they can't work the same way
because they are in the most fundamental
ways different all the major moments we
love from Dragon Ball Z that Vegeta
facilitated happened to coincide with
key moments from within the structure of
a character his Eagle focus returned to
destroy 19 his defense of his son trunks
his sacrifice everything he did be it
good or bad was informed first and
foremost by the character arc structure
he was a part of the moral arc in the
manga is somewhat interesting for some
of the reasons I spoke of today but also
others I plan to touch on when I review
that arc after it's finished but in
short while the manga handles his
character differently than the anime
does with some major changes it always
finishes the same way this is the first
arc that has led the way in quite some
time in the mangas and I'm very
interested to see the position
characters take and the consequences of
the arc to take a hold of the story once
all
is said and done in conclusion from my
perspective Dragon Ball super anime
feels exceptionally shallow in a lot of
areas there's zero effort made to create
a story that flows outside of its arcs
bar 1 or 2 easily missed moments Vegeta
Gohan piccolo and many other characters
in Dragon Ball affirm much of their
success through emotional growth and
struggle as I was applied in believable
original and specific ways over the
course of a long winding narrative
Vegeta acting as he does in Super will
never achieve what it did for him in the
original story
it's tone-deaf it's amateurish and it's
the perfect recipe for what became
Dragon Ball super z' boring sequel
thanks for watching
[Music]